its
Hello
Hello, hi, you might notice something different.
I have a heart monitor today in the top corner.
Yeah, hi, um, welcome, thank you for coming.
Um, this is gonna be our last Poppy Playtime stream.
I'm not gonna, um, put my pants, no.
Um, yeah, this is gonna be our last Poppy Playtime stream.
Now, I don't know if I'll finish it, um, I don't know.
I'll go as far as I can, but I didn't realize how hot it would be today.
It's like 32 degrees Celsius outside and it's probably even hotter in my
bedroom because my bedroom is the hottest room in the apartment.
It faces the sun, so the sun, you know, hits the bedroom directly
and gets really hot in here.
So, it will not be an endurance stream.
Um, it'll just be, I'm gonna play for, uh, as long as I can until I get too hot,
hot and give up.
Yeah, or I just get too frustrated and give up.
So, uh, yeah.
Um, I, it's not, your resting heart rate is crazy, it's not.
It's very normal, is 100 not normal? I thought 100 for resting heart rate is
normal.
Resting heart rate, between 60 and 100 is normal.
And look, I'm even going lower.
60 and 100 is normal.
It's on the higher end. Yeah, I know it's on the higher end.
I know it's on the higher end, I'm aware.
Um, but that's normal.
It was more than 100? Well, that was because I was walking around, okay?
I was setting up and I was walking around and, um, I'm gonna take off the,
pillow underneath me, because, oh, I just made my calendar fall off the wall.
Uh-oh.
Um.
Alright, so now there is a pin on the floor that was pinning my calendar to the
wall, and I hope I don't step on it because I don't see it anywhere.
Alright, well, if I, if I randomly screech, you know what happened.
I stepped on a pin. Okay, um, um, what did I want to talk about?
Fucking, uh, uh, I had, hold on, let me, let me, let me, um,
right, I ordered a new capture card. I got an Elgato capture card.
Um, I got an Elgato capture card, so this
should work because it was expensive and it was by a trusted brand instead of
like a random Amazon brand. So, and the, the first capture card I got was like
$20, like I understand if it breaks or maybe it's not suited for the,
for the switch, I don't know, but this time it should work,
um, for sure, so I 100% aim to be playing, um, Mario Kart while drunk.
Next week, now next week, sorry, um,
next week we will be, um, um, a Guerrilla week, and the reason it'll be a Guerrilla
week is, so a Guerrilla week basically means every
stream will be unplanned. I will try to keep every stream out,
like I will start around the usual stream time,
so like, you know, I won't randomly start a stream at like
3 p.m. EDT, um, or like 11 a.m. EDT, I'll keep them all at 6 p.m. EDT,
whatever, whatever the usual stream time is for you, I know I'm not streaming at
the usual time, we're a little early, so that way, um, at least
it'll be like the usual time that I stream, so maybe you can make it.
I'm sorry that, uh,
I'm sorry it's Guerrilla, my cousin is coming over,
we're making last-minute plans to visit, you know, all these crazy places with
her because it's her first time here, so we want to make it fun for her,
of course, I realized I didn't turn my ring light on,
um, you know, we want to make it fun for her, so yeah, I won't be home,
I'll be, I'll be going around, um, thank you for the $5 Guerrilla week,
um, right, fansly, uh, I have not set up my fansly, I am currently not,
I'm not prioritizing fansly, I haven't even set it up,
you're not gonna get, I think, um, some girls are doing a fansly
stream like tomorrow or the day after, I'm sorry I'm not planning that,
I, um, like, I'm, I'm, I'm gonna be busy very much next week, so
I'm sorry, I know a lot of you were excited for it, I was excited too, but
I, uh, I, like, I, uh, you know, I got other stuff to do,
I apologize, I have to spend some time with, um, you know, my,
my cousin and I have to, you know, I, isn't that terrible, no, that's okay,
um, I'm excited to meet her, well, I've met her before, but I'm excited to,
you know, have fun with her, sounds very fun,
yes, it will be fun, family obligation, it's understandable, yeah, it's family fun,
it's not obligations, I just do it because it's like, you know,
unless you're here for the first time, so let's, you're visiting,
you're visiting us for the first time, so let's have fun together, yeah,
um, so, yes, I'll tell you one way or another
that I'm doing it, it, I don't think it'll be on our
weekly schedules, I will probably have to notify you, like,
on our, on our, um, audio schedules, uh, that, like, I,
sorry, I'm, like, talking fast, I'll, I'll probably have to notify you on our
audio schedules, um, for, like, Patreon, where, where,
where I say, like, you know, this, or doing, or doing this
subject for, you know, all four audios of Patreon, and then maybe at the end,
I'll have, like, um, the days for fansly streams for the month,
um, like that, and obviously don't expect, like,
weekly fansly streams, yeah, um, I think
that's all I had to say, um,
I'm glad you're patient, thank you for being patient,
I'll try to have the thigh cupping video out for next week, so that way you
still have a little bit of me, you know,
um, if Momosa is able to get me her, um, part of the ASMR
video we have together, I might be able to have that out too,
it depends on her, but it's okay, no pressure on her, you know,
she's, she's very busy too, so like, uh, we'll see, it's not a big deal though,
um, that was my day, I didn't do too much in the morning,
we had our meeting, that was, that was, I, uh, we talked about a lot more than I
was expecting to talk about.
Is the same time of today the guerrilla stream?
Is that the same time of today the guerrilla stream?
No, they'll be at the usual streaming time, so six.
Six, is the, the usual streaming time, 6 p.m. EDT,
or, uh,
um,
fucking, I don't know the other time songs that I, that I stream in, I don't know the
other ones, yes, two hours from now, or one hour and
40 minutes from now is my usual time, uh,
yeah, I don't expect too many guerrillas, I'll try my best whenever I'm
home to do something, but I'm not going to be home a good chunk of it, so yeah,
so productive, not really, not really, truly I do nothing,
truly I do nothing, most of the time I'm just sitting there stressing about how
I should be doing something, but I'm not,
so truly like I don't do anything, like I say, oh I'll have the thigh cupping
video next week, you think I have the thigh cupping
video ready, I don't have it, I don't have a script for it,
I didn't record it, I don't even have art for it, I'm just saying that,
I'm just saying that in hopes that it'll pressure me to do it,
so yeah, like, most of the time I'm rot-maxing, I'm just feeling bad that I
have to leave you next week, so I'm like, okay, let me,
that thigh cupping video I wanted to do for so long, let me do that now,
so that I, you know, I have something to give you while I'm gone,
but yeah, uh,
so don't call me productive, because truly I ain't doing shit,
okay, um, let me start the game, let me open scene to start the game,
I don't have a controller today, I was just too lazy to plug it in
and I feel like we're at a, you know, we're at a intense part of the
game, so I don't, I'm not even gonna use the controller for a good amount of it,
you know, um,
why can't, uh, why can't I find the game?
Probably play time, there it is, play, okay,
found from Twitter, ah, thank you for coming from Twitter,
thank you, thank you, Mr. Light, yes, we're meeting Mr. Light, oh, that's loud,
and I'm going to, um,
gonna turn off my music,
uh, turn that on, turn off discord call, because I'm not in a discord call right now,
um, for now on, for now I'm gonna lurk, oh, okay, thank you for lurking,
can she clear the, the worst part of the game? I don't know, I'm really, really worried that, um,
I won't be able to clear it, I really hope that, uh,
I really hope that I can, today's underwear color, it's just light pink again,
I'm really sweaty today, I really, really, even when I had the AC on,
I was sweating really bad, it's like, even with the AC on, what happened, what ends up happening
is the top part of my room, sorry, I'm looking up a tutorial on how to clear this chapter, so that way I'll
know how to clear it, um, what happens with the AC when it gets really hot in my room is that
the lower part of my room gets like, decently cool, but literally, if you like, lift your arm
to like, feel the top layer of air in the room, it like, there's like a drastic
temperature difference between the bottom layer of air in my room and the top layer of air in my room,
and that's because the AC can only cool the bottom layer, yeah, hot air rises, so like,
I'm like, sitting here in my desk and like, my feet are cold but my, my, my face is sweaty,
okay, Poppy, playtime, chapter three, uh, walkthrough, walkthrough, no jumpscares, that's so funny,
okay, I'm gonna skip the first one, um, no deaths, okay, thank you,
oh no, I don't expect them to die if they know how to play the game, you know,
get a fan going around to move air, um, should I do that? What the fuck is this ad?
I don't use ad blocker, I know, I'm sorry, ever since YouTube blocked ad blockers,
I got lazy, I don't, and I don't use them, it's not like the ads work, I don't click on them,
um, a fan should help, you're doing fine last time, you just need to find the other power
source at one part, but it's so difficult to find it, like, so difficult, I mean, will you cater to
your lesbian fans? Unfortunately, probably not, you have to, you have to deal with the F4 content,
I'm sorry, I do have old F4A content on my other channel if you want to look at that,
but that's a little different, I understand if you want, if you're here for, if you're here for
Imi, then no, if you're here for any content I've made, then possibly, yeah, no F4F, um, yeah,
but there's a lot of good other content creators that do F4F content here, let me see if I can,
I know, I think it was, um, you can go to Eksumar, E-G-G-S-M-R, she does a lot of
good F4A content, which means female for anyone, like the, the, you know, the pronouns and stuff
used in, um, in the video or, uh, fuck, there was one more, um, oh no, I don't remember her name,
she did a fucking Amonka say it some more, I remember that one, it was funny,
FANGAR, FANGAR does really good F4F content, so there you go, there's my recommendations,
um, if you're looking for that, you're welcome, um, okay, let me look through this walkthrough here,
let me show it to you, okay, let me see,
okay, I forgot how fucking dark this game is, okay, no, give me the full, give me the full screen,
okay, did I, I died, right, so I'm gonna end up at the start, right,
right, thank you, sis, you're amazing, you're welcome,
uh-huh, let me read that, I had, I don't have a tab open even though I should,
let me close my other, I have so many tabs open, why do I have this program open,
oh so I tested it out, I received the vlog camera and I tested it out,
I am so worried about how high deaf it is, you can see everything, you can see every gross
disgusting wrinkle on my finger, you can see every pore, like truly you can see everything,
it's always great to come home to your little sister after a rough day at work, hope you're
doing well sis, oh thank you, thank you for the two dollars,
you'll start when delight triggers delight, any hands in HD, yeah truly you can see everything,
I tested it out and oh my god, you can see everything, it's, it's um, it's rough,
but it's really good quality which is nice, should I um,
man this really, this part, does this part take a long time usually,
wait he, he so easily passed the part that I was stuck on, what the fuck,
what did he do, or is this another part, oh wait I forgot to show it to you, sorry,
sounds useful for brosley streams, oh no no no no no, no it is not,
I will not be using the vlog camera for brosley streams,
is this not the part that I was stuck on, no this wasn't the part that I was stuck on was it,
he passed it so quickly, what the fuck,
oh this is it right, no is it, oh man I'm so confused,
no that seems after,
okay this is the part that I was stuck on,
okay so he sees that, okay, so first he goes down the hall
to this room and what the fuck, oh man I'm gonna have such a hard time finding that,
huh,
so, oh man,
okay so there is a different one, okay, okay I'm so directionally challenged, truly I'm really
really directionally challenged, thank you for being here to lead me, um maybe you can show us
the puppy pad, that's funny, maybe, yeah maybe, I don't know if the, I don't know if the camera
that I got is like better than my phone camera or anything, you want to see the puppy pad in a
high definition, okay,
um is it this one, no that's the window capture, oh there's a game I didn't even notice, okay,
okay thank you for helping me throughout this whole game, I hope we can at least get as far as
possible together, she spiked her heart rate from like low 90, oh oh wait you don't see my heart
here anymore, what the fuck, here it is, oh is that gonna be hard to see, should I put it up here,
okay, um, okay, I'll try to become, I'm a very anxious person, um in general,
first time, no I've been anxious lots of times, or no, how does it go first time?
Are you anxious, yeah, first time, no I've been anxious lots of times, or was it nervous, nervous,
yeah, first time, no, I've been, I've been nervous lots of times, okay, grab that,
yes, nice airplane reference, I never even watched that movie, but yes, I know it's a,
oh fuck how am I supposed to open this door,
all right, oh what the fuck, what the fuck, okay but she goes through doors, right,
um,
you should watch it, I don't know, will I understand the the humor in it, I have a lot of time,
sometimes this is embarrassing, but sometimes I have a hard time understanding the humor in older
movies because, oh no I backed myself into a corner, because like I just don't,
I just don't like recognize like, like if they take a jab at a celebrity or something,
they're like ah ha ha ha, fucking, I don't know, joke about this celebrity or something,
I won't understand it because like, you know, I uh, fuck what do I do here, excuse me,
oh, cute, in me heart, yeah, in me heart, I think it's age, been a while since I last saw it,
she spawns in as you go further along the hallway,
huh,
do I open this door, how do I get this door open without her attacking me,
she moves like a weeping angel, yes I remember that, thank you for the two dollars, thank you,
thank you, when I watched Deadpool we're over in because I wasn't into the lore, but the movie
was still super funny, yeah I wanted to watch that, but um, I couldn't find a, what do I do,
if I turn around she's gonna attack me, should I try to lead her like,
I didn't know if I got too close to her she would attack me,
I didn't know if I got too close to her she would attack me, follow the hallway in me,
don't go in any rooms with the battery, oh okay, okay thank you for the tip,
I'm so lucky that you're here to help, truly I would be so lost in this game, if you weren't here,
okay, the volume is not too loud is it, I want to make sure,
okay,
I keep forgetting that I need to open the door, did it open, yes, okay follow the hallway,
wait wasn't there something here,
wait, oh wait, oh no no no no,
this way right, okay, thank you, that looks right, okay put that, oh there we go,
there we go,
um,
I just want to walk backwards because I'm scared all the time,
I'm scared, I'm spooked,
keep following the hallway to the next door now,
hi Emirates, hi, how was your voice so majestic, what do you mean,
ah, I attached new stickers, I have a bunch of stickers on my desk drawers because I think
they look cute, but now do I go to this door, no, no, do I go to that door, I need to sneeze,
I don't feel, oh, I guess I can keep going this, yes, okay, I need to sneeze again,
hold on, I think I'm okay, thank you for the blessings,
okay, thank you,
um,
do I do anything with this,
wait a minute,
wait no no I'm lost, I went the other way,
follow the hallway again to open the door, it's not this direction is it,
I'm so directionally challenged, I used to have this when I was younger, I made my first mod in
Minecraft world and I was so proud of it because I had all these cool mods in it and I built such a
cool, I built such a cool fucking, oh, I have to open this door with the thing in the room,
right, I built such a cool house with my, with my, with all the mods and stuff, stop,
leave me alone, how am I supposed to get past you, is she gonna attack me, okay, come on,
how am I supposed to get past,
I'm never gonna pass this fucking part, I'm gonna cry,
I made a really nice Minecraft world with all the mods that I had downloaded,
I'm gonna open this door first, okay, and I went on my first ever like expedition
after making the Minecraft world and I immediately got lost and um,
I couldn't find my house anymore and I had to delete the world
because I was literally just lost, what do I do with this again, oh the hallway,
Amy tears, whoa, Amy tears,
come on,
okay,
I really do have goldfish memory, it's a problem,
I tried my best though, okay, so in this room, right, is the,
that's where the, the thing is for that, right, okay, so I need to go in this room,
that's why I always save a screenshot of the coordinates, I didn't know how to use coordinates,
I still very, I still very badly know how to use coordinates, like my coordinate
knowledge is like, here let me get you a little closer here, okay, okay,
oh come on, am I gonna be able to make this, how did I do it last time,
oh please don't attack me just because I got close to you, this is the furthest I can be,
please don't attack me, I'm scared to get close,
okay,
you can grab it from outside the hallway, through the window or what, can I grab it through the window,
oh, I don't understand, through the door,
oh,
grabbing it as you're leaving, okay,
oh, thank you,
okay, and then the door behind me should open, right, okay, there we go, thank you, thank you,
thank you, you're so helpful, thank you, I wouldn't be, I wouldn't be able to figure that out myself,
okay, now this hallway ends, so I'm gonna go through here, I'm drinking,
okay,
no, is that the double door, this isn't the double door situation is it,
is it, this is the double doors, I'm not going backwards, am I,
oh shit, no, no this is something else, wait, what, did I just go in a circle, wait,
Amy would it help if you just jump doing the puzzle and just check the map first to see where
you have to go and then do the puzzle, is there a map in this game,
if there's a map in this game I feel like it would be cheating,
the map, you can open the door with the power, oh the power,
okay, hold on, it's right in front of you, this door,
oh she's gonna attack me, no, okay, she didn't, okay,
I feel like Loki, I'm going in a circle, okay here's the double, okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay, here's the double door situation right, I remember that whole, no,
no maybe not, maybe I'm going a little crazy,
what's down here,
double door is after the door in front of you, okay,
okay, okay, here it is, okay, here it is, no, no this is another door,
how far away did I get so fast,
um, we all remember that whole,
so wait, there's nothing here right, no, you have to grab the power from the door you just
opened to open this next one, so the one over there, I have to grab power from the one I just opened,
okay, we'll try to remain calm,
um,
isn't it kind of far though, I feel like it's very, very far,
I have to grab power from this door to the next one,
you're close to the end, weren't you, I have no clue, you're doing very well, thank you,
I feel like I'm too stupid to play this game,
it is,
I'll try,
it's not gonna,
I'm stuck, fuck, oh okay,
okay, thank you, okay I did it,
um,
okay, here's the double doors, or the, yeah the double, okay, okay, now we're back to how,
we made it back to where I got stuck, okay, let me just locate them first, so I know one of them
is in this room, right, I want, I want to locate them first, so that I, oh fuck where is she coming
from, okay there she is,
one of them is definitely in this room, correct, yes, okay there it is, let me locate the next one
now, let me locate the next one, come through the, come through, okay, okay, it's the hardest deck
builder I've ever played and I'm not good at deck builders, Poppy playtime, is the hardest deck
builder you've ever played,
you can't hear the game,
okay, so he went, let me just make sure where he went,
where did he go, let me look at the tutorial again,
okay, so he, there's the door, so he went down the hall right in front of the doors,
and then he went in the classroom on the right,
and then he went through another, a hole after the classroom on the right,
got, got the, the thing, and then fucking, uh, what,
what,
I'm too directionally challenged for this, okay, it was down, okay, it looks like it's down this way,
is it in here, oh come on bitch, oh fuck, where is she,
okay, there she is, is it in this room,
yes, okay, um,
let me get her a little, a little poster so that I can go around her,
okay, no, it's not in this room, what, is it through this hole,
okay, no, I just went out of that room, is it in this room,
it's in this room, okay, okay, I don't know if I can get it first try,
but I'll give it a shot, or maybe, hold on, let me wait until I'm closer to the door,
we're gonna big brain this, I'm gonna wait until it runs out and I'm closer to the door,
come on run out, run out, oh my god, I thought she went back into the hallway, it scared me, okay,
what, it ran out, oh no, it didn't run out, it didn't run out, it didn't run out,
get it, get it you dumb bitch, oh, we did it, we did it, I'm so happy right now, oh my god,
okay, no, I'm checking, I can't, I can't pass this moment up, I'm checking what the tutorial
is doing after this, I can't, I need to get past this part, I can't, okay, he goes under the door,
then what, the stickers on my desk keep coming, okay, he finds, okay, it's behind him,
he finds the power battery thing, puts it in the door on the left of him,
or I guess on the right depending on which way you're facing, okay, okay, okay, I'll do that,
I'll do that, I know it's probably sucky to, okay, so it was behind him here, there it is,
give it to me, and he puts it in this door, oh you fucking hoe, okay, okay, okay, okay,
I need to get past Mr. Light, okay, after he does that, what does he do then,
he goes and opens the door, oh wait, what,
okay, well he moves the thing away from the door, finds the other power source thing in the room,
okay, and puts it in the next door on the other side, and then grabs the one from the previous door,
and then what, dude, no, do you not know what you're doing,
oh he's trying to just get her into a corner, okay,
are you gonna put it in the door, you're urging me right now, okay, okay, I can do that,
okay, I'm really, I'm really um,
take it, I'm really focusing in right now, take it, grab it, there we go, I'm locked the fucking,
okay,
okay, puts it in this door, grab this one, shit,
put it in, put it in,
okay, okay, then what, then what, then what, after he goes to the door, you have
here back seating the walkthrough, dude, I just don't like it when they're not like direct with
what they need to do, like be direct about what you're doing right now, you know, don't play games
in this game, it's not a game, opens the door in that room, grabs the power source,
so he grabs the, one of the thingies from the room, puts it in,
grabs another thing, and grabs the other battery from the same door, here let me show you the
the thing, that way um,
not left on it, there, now you can see what he's doing too,
I kind of forgot to be honest, what did he just do,
so he's going to the, he just moved the two power supplies from that room to the next one,
oh but you have to, oh you have to, oh okay, wait, I think I understand what's going on,
oh okay, I think I understand what's going on, okay, okay, I understand what's going on here,
okay, open the door,
here we go, I love watch alongs, I'm sorry, I'm sorry,
okay, oh my god, okay no, I need you to get further away from me right now,
come this way, come this way, come this way, okay,
okay, take that out, and I think I need to get closer to it right, put it in,
right, did it go in, it went in, it's fine, you're cute, okay, I just really want to get past this
part, I really want to get past this part, okay, I need you to get closer to me so that,
okay, that was too close, that was too close, okay,
okay, I think I can do it, no I'm too scared, get closer, get closer,
come here, come here, come here, closer, okay, I'm really scared of her,
okay,
fuck, there we go, oh okay, okay,
you like bullying me,
I'm surprised my heart rate is so low, I'm fucking, I'm scared and frustrated of her,
okay, so is she coming,
oh okay, wait, no, I need to get closer to the door, oh fuck, oh fuck,
oh my god, I keep losing her and it's scaring me,
get away, take the, is this the door,
why is this lasting so long on my hand, there we go, okay,
okay, okay, holy shit, she's not stopping anymore, she's not stopping anymore,
she's not stopping anymore, I'm scared she didn't stop, is the 30k on x or youtube, I've already
gotten 30k on on twitter, pull the lever, there's a lever, oh the lever right in front of me,
pull the lever right in front of me, right, okay, wait, I need to pee first though,
I need to pee first, hold on, I'll be right back, I'll pee, I'll pee and then I'll
and I need to get more water too,
you
You
Hello, I peed why is her heart rate going up on the toilet cuz I'm moving
I'm moving
Why did a bunch of you donate a dollar I mean, thank you
Did you wash your hands I did I did
Okay
Hold on let me
Let me watch what he does after that
I'm scared so
After he gets to the door
Run pull a lever
Oh, that was scary, okay, I'm scared. I'm not gonna be able to pull it
Okay, I pulled it
We did it
We did it is the piss tax the p-tax they're flushing for you cuz you forgot I remembered to flush
Sorry, sorry, I spoiled myself. I really I just didn't want to fuck it up. I can't do that part again. It was so stressful
Uh, I was really worried. I wasn't gonna be able to oh I was really really worried
I wasn't gonna be able to get past it and the whole stream would be just me struggling to get past it. I'm sorry
Okay
It is very quiet
Oh
Okay, I thought he really wanted me to jump
What the fuck is this when did I get this hand is this a shooter game now
Oh
Am I gonna start shooting people
You want to risk you want me to respond to your last don't know
I
Don't know how to help you with that fucking eat better drink more water fucking
Don't jerk it as much take a break have a kick
Next part is awful why
Oh
It's just this okay
Wait, where do I go from here?
Where do I go from here is it just down there jump down
Okay
Oh, I like it when they make it easy that's nice of them
Oh
No, probably not
Really they didn't make it easy enough. I'm sorry. I
Wasn't sure where to go. I think there's like tape and TV somewhere. There's a TV there
But I don't see oh the tape is right here
Go in
How do I oh
Let's just get this shit been dropped and go
What is that paw
I take it you're not a fan of this place are you nope never liked the feel of it
I mean, why is it just a paw?
Richie the claw
Lights and painted skies hell. We're not even allowed to talk. It's not my father isn't that
Why do you want to talk to the kids? Why do you want to talk to the kids?
Trying to stop being so pissed off all the time
My wife says I'm a lovely man, but I gotta control my temper
Rich
But I always like that about you. Yeah
How do I reach these kids
You know Richie
With my retirement coming up you have to park or a bit in the next section
That's pushing hard for me to choose my replacement. I'm actually thinking about giving the role to you
Really? Yeah, really
Nothing official yet, but sorry. I'm messing with my face. That's one of my models
Bucking up an honest hard-working man, but he wanted to did all the kids. Why would you give it to him?
Let's say your chances are pretty good
Wow
Don't know what to say
I'm just glad to see not everyone in this place has it out for me. I'm not picking my nose. No
It's cat naps Paul. Why? Why am I just seeing his paw?
Did they not did they not have a stock image a stock photo did they not have enough budget for actors for that part?
Am I supposed to jump through here wait? Oh, no
Okay, so here's where I didn't know what to do
Here's where I wasn't sure where to go look down
Wait, oh
Hold on. Oh, oh, it has to be activate. Oh, okay. Oh fuck. Okay. Oh wrong. Oh shit
Okay
Okay, oh
Fuck wrong. I'm so bad at this
Okay, this parkour isn't so bad when you got a jump boost
Are you sure I was right there
Don't tell me I have to go all the way back down. Oh my god. I didn't know there was a timer
Okay
Go
Ah
Okay, did I make it in time it was easy it was okay. It was okay. I am locked in
Do I need to go fuck down there? Oh
It's saving oh
Wait, it was Q and R
Mmm, that doesn't look right probably there
Can I just press two? Oh, I can okay
That was close, okay, and then this one is
Probably gonna go there
And then this one gonna go here
I
Feel like I'm getting it. Oh, I'm not getting it
Okay, I'm getting it now
Now the only thing is I don't know what happens after this
Did it work? No, wait, let's try let's try this again. Hold on hold on hold on
Over here there we go
Oh
I'm hearing a noise you move the last one too far. Oh, did I did I
Perfect
Okay, well, let's go see if that did anything
Go up the last one isn't aiming towards this one. Oh
This one is supposed to aim towards this
There we go. Okay. Now I get it now. I get it now. I get it I
Understand I aimed it towards that one even though this is what shoots that okay
I'm learning. I feel like this game has has um
Made my IQ higher I
Feel like it's making me learn things. Uh, excuse me
Okay
Like if I took an IQ test before and after this game, I feel like my IQ would be higher
Wait what
I
I'm so I'm so smart. I'm figuring it out so well
Praise me
Praise me, I deserve it. Okay
Scary music look now if you look down that is Katnap Katnap
I
Keep looking at the statue
What are you talking about what statue
That that thing good girl Amy you're doing so well
That's Katnap the orange like this. Why do I keep looking at it?
Oh
Wait
Katnap was there before it praying do I have a gun because I need to shoot Katnap
Is that why they gave me a gun you you absolutely missed it. Sorry, I don't know what I was looking for
No, oh
Then why do I have a gun?
Which
Do I go in here wait did I just go backwards or
Did I just go wait, I'm so confused what
That's where you came from
Okay this direction
Okay
No
Any any um
What was I supposed to do there
I
What the fuck is that thing what uh
I'm scared
Oh
Where did that thing was I just not supposed to press this button
They're gonna be on many of them are you gay? Why are you acting so gay?
You need you need the gun to keep the craters away from you they don't like the fire. Oh, okay
Thank you for the $1
The alert does scare me
I'm surprised I'm even aiming correctly
Oh, there's more oh
He's glitched out so it's they just come from holes
I can't fucking see any
Like I'm so scared
This is another one of those stupid situations where I have to shoot them all
I'm getting scared
No, just follow the path driving off so you can continue
Holy shit, where do they all come from?
How do I how do I where do I continue up there?
Estrogen made me like this
Okay, well then stop drinking stop taking estrogen what oh
Ah
Oh my god, I'm getting scared. I'm gonna help help help
Get out of my way. Oh my god
Go up the ramp
They respawn infinite infinitely just keep going up
You have to go up the ramp just keep moving, okay
Okay, okay, okay, okay
Shoot that one get out of my way
This way
There's one that comes from this way right
I
Ignored that hole. I hope that was okay. Oh
I fucking hate mazes
Hello am I at a dead end right now
Run like the wind bullseye, what does that mean I had a dead end
Am I supposed to go towards them come at me hole
Am I supposed to go towards them and I'll or away from them. Oh
Did I make it oh
Fuck this shit
Oh
You're scaring me
Okay pause we got to explain what you mean
Are those mini-deranged pin pals they don't look like pin pals
And in me gonna hate this entire I don't like I don't like I don't like small creatures
That's why I don't like kids. There's gonna be buns on the floor
And I have to press them or shoot them
Blocks you need to push onto the button floor
They look like in me cuz they're the same shut up
Oh my god, oh
No, oh, I'm gonna get fucked here
What happened am I supposed
I'm just going whichever direction it lets me go into at this point
Thank you for the fort
Thank you for the fort honey. You're cute when you're scared. Thanks
I'm going back this way cuz I don't I don't know
What about this way
Do I push this on to the button
Is this what you mean yeah, how do I oh wait
Did I do it
Two of them are you serious, how do I get to the other one both you're here, maybe
Damn it on the other side did it save I don't think it's saved did it
I
Get to the other side of the room it didn't save no
Okay
Okay, okay
Wait, this looks different. Or am I going crazy?
Are you gay? This looks different so gay. It looks look one of them is one of them is one of them is
Which do you prefer cats or dogs? Um, I prefer I prefer cats I
Hate the way they sound they're like little groundlings
Go to the other side I'm glad it saved at least
Okay, which which other side you speak in groundling
This side probably right we got
Oh
Are you serious right now, is it seriously stuck kill me kill me kill me please
Thank you
Maybe you need two hands, I brought it down it
It has two hands on the block
Okay
Okay, okay, I don't even remember which direction to go
I'll be honest
I'm gonna get back
And then I kind of dangerous to be down here
Okay
Huh
She's
What happened
Okay, oh
They're still around me aren't they I can still hear them
What
Not that way
Well, then why do they let me go are you gay why are you acting so gay I
Do like dogs I'm guessing I'm gonna be attacked by a dog. I have a dog. Okay. No, I was just here close door
I
Geese
There's nothing up top then why do they make an up top area is it just the illusion of choice that I chose to go that direction
What is this are these candles, what are these?
Yeah, I'm is this like toy jail
Wait it opened for a second what the section is gonna be oh oops, that scared me. How do I take this off?
Oh dog lives here are farf I'm so leading
I
Should jump scare you sometimes that might be a little mean though
Really
Why are you bleeding like your robot
That's what I do to hair it takes to
I don't like how it's throbbing down there
The toilet
Hello
The wooden floor
What
I
Stand on the board look down
What do I need to go through all of that again and his whole rant about you need to dip it then you can do it
Are you gay why are you acting so gay?
Of course, I still like dogs
You almost fell with stood on solid ground
I was supposed to fall through the door stay on the boards when he starts chasing you will break. Oh
these
All right, got it. Hello. I've come to speak with you
Break break
Hello, oops, that's a bad idea
There we go
Okay, oh, this is just like chapter one where he chased us through the vents
Okay, I'm guessing I can't shoot him right
Oh, oh, oh, no, do I have to shoot the little guys too? It skipped most of his lines yet
Isn't he wonderful who's the prototype is the thing chasing me the prototype
But wait, I got attacked by something did I go down the wrong path?
Straight left and right, okay, okay, I'll try doing that
Straight left and then right
Okay, that wasn't too bad do not take wrong turns cuz he spawns okay
Is it cuz I took a wrong turn that he spawned straight straight straight left and right straight left right straight left right
straight left right, okay
Straight left right. I'm ready
Yeah
Are you gay
Right right right right right
He's scared
Left
Sorry that's me
I
Do get a little toxic with games, I'm sorry
That's why I don't play league because I would probably tell people to kiss their sister if I play league I
Used to do that in bed wars. I would get really toxic with bed wars
That's the only kind of competitive game that I used to play
It's left not left right. It's right left
Okay, you know what I think I will just not go that direction next time and then we'll figure it out from there. I
Would get toxic with bed wars
I would
Go go
Okay
Okay, so just keep going straight after that
I
Might not remember
Okay, here it is keep going straight
Oh my god
You want to see me play bed wars I
Get toxic in bed wars. I'm not even that good at it either
I'm not even that good at it
I miss the door
I
The guy said straight left right was right
Was he I don't know
He looks different when he gets evil when he you know
Yeah
Okay, let's see if we can do this
You got this and me you got this don't get stuck
Like I feel like if I make one tiny wrong move like that if I get stuck a little bit I'm scared. I'm gonna die
You know
Oh, come on, I swear to God if this is it, okay
Shh, I don't know which to okay
Okay
Was that just a luck thing
Was I just supposed to not take that one
Like how was I supposed to know when I return left don't go through any of the tubes. Oh
Oh
Okay
I was almost done to just turn left there, okay, okay, thank you
Hello
It's just a luck thing it's your first time it is my first time
Okay, okay, I'm just trying to stay calm at this point
I'm surprised my heart rate is surprisingly low for how stressed I am
Straight here
Shit did I go the right way
Okay, so after this room I go left
Or in this room you just go left
Shit shit
Did I do it or am I still in danger?
Oh man, oh man, that's scaring me you did it
I
Should I go down here
Is this a save screen is a saving for me
No, oh many out cheese
I'm really glad you're okay. I'm not
It just saved okay
Oh
See before
He almost died but
But they say that the prototype saved his life
living up his own freedom in the process
The prototype is a superhero and has saved this place
So Katnack treats him like a god killing everyone that opposes him
Us included if we're not careful. What is the prototype is that the thing that scare you? No
You thought that was terrifying. Just wait until you see the real thing
Anyways, we're really close to the end
You're going to the counsellor's office instead. It's not ideal, but it should have enough juice
If you can get that generator going and plug it in
I think we'll be done and keep your eyes open for Katnack
Every shadow
It means only when we're building the banners is there still good amount of game left
Thank you Oley, okay, I think what I'll do
I
Think what let me turn that off
That's not the right thing this way guys, okay
It's way too hot right now to finish the game
I
Think what I'll do
What did I have planned for today hold on I have a planner
Yeah, I'm a real adult and I have a planner for on one of the pages of my planner just fell out
Okay
So I think what I'll do is I'll end here because I I'm not over just
Stop trying to get me naked. I know what you're fucking doing. Yeah, I have a planner
I I've been trying to get organized and
Plan content because I really want to post more like ASMR and stuff
So, yeah, um
Yeah, I'm a big girl so um what I'm going to do
Is I'm gonna end here because I did want I did have to record a little bit
I'm gonna record the thigh cupping. Yeah, that's what I'll do and
That way you can have it
Yeah, I I did
What I what I'm able to do is like when I plan stuff and write it down
I'm able to get like a good amount of what I want finished in a week
But the problem is as I'm not able to do anything else
Like it's like I can get what I want done, but then I can't do anything else. So I still have to work on like
Routines in my day. I still struggle with that
But um, I think I'm getting somewhere. I think I'm getting somewhere slowly
Maybe yeah, you'll get my thighs
You hear that I
Don't know what people like in thigh cupping
I think I'll have to watch strong is that cupping and see how she did it
Do I just put the 3d on my thighs into my thighs and go?
Like do I oil my thighs up or something to get them wet like how does it work?
Same in some ways. I just list whatever I'm after and then put numbers on which ones I got to get done sooner
Which ones I already got progress with oh, I should I should do that too
Executive function isn't easy bb steps. I'm trying to get there
Please crash the 3d
I'll try I don't I don't see I don't know how here. Let me hear how strawny does hers
Like is it literally just shwerp shwerp shwerp with your thighs?
Let me hear her
She talks to
Oh
It feels like I'm in her belly this was this sounds like the okay. I she talks to I thought I was okay
Okay, I think I have a good idea of what to do. Okay
It's like using hands with thighs
Maybe I'll do some slapping too actually wait will you two think that's like clapping if I slap my thighs?
Like will you two be like nah, that's not safer work. I don't know
Maybe I won't slap them too much then I won't slap them too much
Okay, oh
I was getting confused it said she be was live, but she's doing on a member stream. That's what okay, uh
Strony is live with Lego. Do you want to go read Strony?
Here we'll read strong
Strony with low Lego Lego lord of the wings
If in doubt just tell YouTube come that you're only slapping your thighs. They don't care
They don't care at all. They'll they'll they'll assume whatever they want to assume and remove the video
They they do not know even my my kiss
Audio got demonetized. I'm not demonetized. It got limited ads even though I literally only kissed once it was literally like a
And that's it but it still got limited ads even though it was such a such as more little kiss part
You know whatever it's okay. Not that big of a deal not that big of a deal
Okay
YouTube why
I don't know
They're really against kisses any sort of kisses. They're really really against yeah
But thank you for coming. Um
I will see you tomorrow with uh
Or me and Kaifu Lulu are drawing our pony sonas and we might do a little bit more than that
We might do a little bit more than just drawing pony sonas
We might do like which which uh my little pony are you like quizzes?
We'll see but I think it'll be fun. Um
We'll try to convert you into being my little pony fans. We're we're gonna try to convince you into
Into watching my little pony. We'll see if we can do it
It's a good show. It's a good show. Okay. I thought it was stupid at first too, but you'll see it's a good it's a good show
Okay, yeah, I'll see you tomorrow. That's a uh, that's the usual stream time. Um, yeah, I'll see you tomorrow. Bye. Love you, pookie
Oh